moi j'aurais demandé pardon à ma maman
que j'adore très que j'adore énormément
évidemment comme des garçons de leur
maman ou les filles voilà elle habite
loin habite à biarritz et à chaque fois
j'étais au téléphone elle me dit que je
suis un mauvais fiche la coupe ont très
bien parce que je ne l'appelle jamais et
voilà je sais que j'ai deux soeurs elles
appellent pratiquement tous les deux
jours et moi je n'appelle jamais
pourtant d'aller là avec mon chien avec
mon petit edgar
et voilà et donc je voulais demander
pardon ce que c'est vrai qu'à chaque
fois que les au téléphone je me dis ça
images à partir de cette fois ci je vais
l'appeler plus souvent glp tous les 2
jours 3 jours et j'ai honte de le dire
mais les semaines passent et celle appel
malheureusement peut-être tous les deux
mois et je m'en veux mais même en
voulant je n'arrive pas à passer le pas
je ne suis pas un blocage selon stefan
non maman je t'aime et j'aime bien ta
plus du sommet même quand je t'appelle
pas je pense très fort à toi voilà ce
parce que je t'appelle pas que je pense
pas toi mais dont on sait qu'on a
entendu votre message
elle vous regarde n'aura tous les soirs
me dis heureusement que je regarde la tv
dont ça va coûter encore vivant a déjà
entendu jean michel est ce qu elle au
téléphone avec nous commencez vous
n'avez plus de forfaits on l'appeler
nous est ce que est ce qu'elle est là
madame madame l'allemagne basse et
michel michel michel mas merci d'être
avec nous ce soir au téléphone c'est la
maman de jean michel aulas quand même
elle m'a roddick lui roddick lui ma
maman tu me le dis à chaque fois tu me
sarr proches que tu me fais
régulièrement
donc voilà donc je te promets et voit la
syrie comptent sur lui pour me le
rappeler de taper beaucoup plus souvent
c'est vrai que je suis gosse je
culpabilise énormément
voilà surtout que j'ai deux soeurs qui
elle tu appelles tout le temps et moi je
n'appelle pas donc je vais taper
beaucoup plus haut michel le jour et
c'est très simple et très vive et puis
ben merci à thierry d'état va bien merci
à chelles vous êtes fiers d'eux jean
michel maire ou pas de votre fils oui
oui oui parce que il me téléphone pas
souvent mais il est tellement gentil que
je
au début juste un petit peu tâche et
puis voilà ça se passe près vite parce
que avait été très il est très gentil je
peux pas lui en vouloir longtemps
voilà bah merci michel ça fait du bien
cette séquence de pardon mais bizarre
d'avoir non mais c'est vrai